What happens to three hundred US dollars when
they are put through the Clockworks?
The first hundred dollars was put through
on the setting Coarse.
It produced a puddle of ink, and a pile of
cotton and plastic.
All in all, the materials weighed about the
same amount as the original stack of cash.
The second hundred dollars was placed in the
machinery, set to 1:1.
It produced seventy-five euros in cash.
The third hundred dollars, run through the
machine on the setting Fine, produced a shareholder’s
note for “Soap from Corpses Products”
in the amount of one hundred dollars.
Long story short, it probably isn’t a good
idea to try to use SCP-914 to increase the
value of one’s money.